for the first time in 17 years a federal  prison inmate was executed this morning  Daniel Lewis Lee received the lethal  injection in Indiana after the US  Supreme Court allowed the execution to  proceed he was convicted of murdering  three members of an Arkansas family back  in 1996 including an eight-year-old girl  Lee told witnesses this morning though  that he didn't do it  the High Court with conservative  justices in the majority voted five to  four overnight to reverse the lower  court rulings those courts had been  concerned with what they called an  unconstitutional risk of pain when it  comes to lethal injection